[Music]
foreign
are manufacturers just like we are right
we're part of their supply chain having
a secure environment a secure network it
improves their supply chains as well
there are regulations that we need to
follow that it says you know all that
that is specifically called out to have
these kind of tools in place
so Chronicle ladies are the same
solution all of the logs for all of the
systems that we have around the world
they go straight in there Chronicle
provides you know the flexibility that
we need it is key for us to actually
keep up with the regulations that they
are right now and whatever that is
coming in the future
once that we transition to Chronicle we
start seeing the results right away we
start receiving alerts that we never
seen before right anybody in the same
role that I am is going to see the
benefit right away that's one of the
keys with chronicle chronicle will allow
you to actually run the queries that you
are looking for they're easy to to make
with Chronicles Sim anybody on my team
can actually just go
start working on it and find the results
right away we can put together the story
the same day we don't have to wait for
an expert to come back over here and
help us to actually find the information
that we have anybody can do it some of
the other benefits that we have with
Chronicle it is the flexibility and and
the all the power that it comes with it
when there's an incident that you need
information right away you need to be
able to run a query the response are
instance you can actually quickly get
information of you know of what happened
put together that history and be able to
remediate it almost immediately
if you're considering to go with
Chronicle or with cideris I will tell
you to not wait once that you migrate to
a tool like this you can start seeing
you know the difference
it is hard to explain when you when you
don't know what you're missing when you
are filtering your logs to only a little
recommendation from your provider you
know you wanna you wanna full picture of
everything
Chronicle will allow you to do that
we're pretty happy we think that going
with Chronicle was the right move
Chronicle is easy to use it gives us
what we need right and it is the perfect
solution that we're looking for
foreign